but you know who's not who's not
struggling right now in the United
States the people at FoxNews well some
of the shareholders might be losing a
little bit of money because they're
struggling to get advertisers but the
on-air personalities including the ones
that you've really probably never heard
of oh they're doing great and you know
why they're doing great because it turns
out according to a new report from Media
Matters shared exclusively with The
Daily Beast they're pretty much all
shills for the Republican Party and
they're all being paid huge sums of
money to go out and give speeches or
make appearances for Republican
candidates and the Republican Party
itself this is a fascinating new report
because we've all known for a very long
time that Fox News is a wing of the
Republican Party or maybe the Republican
Party is a wing of Fox News I don't even
know which way that goes anymore
it could be either/or I'm starting to
think Fox News might be the one calling
the shots here but nonetheless here are
some of the numbers here as reported by
The Daily Beast the five co-hosts Greg
Gutfeld earned more than $36,000 in 2017
speaking at a Washington Republican
Party fundraiser Jeanine Pirro
reportedly made thirty five thousand at
a fundraiser for Pennsylvania Republican
gubernatorial candidate Scott Wagner in
2018 Fox and Friends weekend host Pete
hagseth made close to twenty thousand on
a series of speeches at official
fundraisers and events for Republicans
in 2018 and then he got Laura Ingraham
who you know very hate-filled woman she
only got paid $12,500 in 2016 for an
event addressing the Sangamon County
Republican Central Committee so I think
Laura Ingraham probably needs a better
handler because everybody else is making
thirty thirty five thousand dollars
you're getting like 12 grand and you're
speaking at a Republican you know
Central Committee we also know obviously
Sean Hannity's campaign with Donald
Trump he's been up there on stage with
him Fox News and the Republican Party
are one in the same now in this new
report from Media Matters kind of proves
that they're on the payroll basically
and here's the worst part
any other network would fire these
people networks have rules in place that
say you can't go out there and be a
shill for any particular political party
you can't speak at their events you
can't give them money Keith Oberman got
suspended from MSNBC for that in 2010 so
they at least try to pretend that
they're not partisan Fox News they don't
care you want to go be with Trump
onstage go for it you want to give money
get money by speaking on behalf of
Republican candidates do your thing and
that's why Fox News is so toxic and so
dangerous for this country I want to
thank David Pakman for letting me sit in
these past two days if you want more
from me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire
follow me on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook at fair and balanced thank you
very much for watching see you next time